all right it's time for another doctor's
our live it's time for another dr.
Sadler AMA session I've got already got
some questions lined up here so people
want to ask other questions you probably
want to get those in before they pile up
too much I'll probably you know I
scheduled these for an hour but we
usually end up going an hour and a half
so let me jump in and start with them so
a EP has a fairly easy one for me
professor Saylor what's your favorite
Nietzsche work and you know I don't
usually think in terms of favorites
anymore but I guess if I was crest on
that I would probably say the one that
has you know long then the one that I go
to the most and that's the genealogy of
morals I think that's a really cool work
you know you've got the stuff about
master slave morality and results a
month in the beginning but then he gets
into all this discussion about
punishment and society and the gods and
and religion and then by the end of it
of course he's making the case that the
men of science of his own time and I'd
say this extends to those who are super
enamored of science and in the present
the if' and WOM science crowd are really
just a bunch of theologians in disguise
and I think he's he's quite right about
that
so yeah the genealogy of morals which
I'm not teaching this semester I'm
teaching Beyond Good and Evil
instead shooting some some videos on
that towards the end of the semester
Molly boy what's your thoughts about
Alberta Moo's absurd
name of the absurd and some sort of
meaning or ethics in in a world that is
marked by absurdity that changed over
time you see you see a development from
the myth of SIF assist to the rebel or
even letters to a German friend
we're talking about one of them suicide
or the one who's posed with the problem
of murder which is what he very early
and the rebel he says that has become
the problem for us now
and he also sets out you could call a
[Music]
with possibilities for ethics
Billy just the character in the stranger
the way I thinks some people take that
as being there's a lot of different
possibilities for how to live out this
relationship of the absurd without
committing what Camus calls metaphysical
suicide all right if if you accept Camus
starting points which he's perfectly
fine to say that you don't have to but
if you accept them and you accept the
need to be consistent that he talks
about as well then what he has to say is
is quite helpful and you could even
believe that you know the entire
universe isn't absurd and still draw
upon what he has to say and get
something out of it all right so here's
a question about music
I know heavy metal as your music of
choice but I see use western classical
music and some of your videos are you a
fan of this music do you have any
favorite composers or works yeah I
actually have quite a few classical
composers who I like
typically we divide things into you know
baroque classical romantic and then
modern and and I I like you know I like
some of the Baroque stuff Bach is is
somebody who I've always found
interesting and also Telamon yeah I'm
not so big on a lot of the heavy
classical stuff you know the kind of
person who does is that he's supposed to
really enjoy as a cultured person I mean
who do I really enjoy a lot of them are
20th century composers like Prokofiev
I mean 19th century too as well
Debussy I like quite a few of his things
the rim ski Korsakoff I'm not you know
somebody who actually listens to a lot
of classical music quite frankly and
yeah you summon in some of my videos
like the Hegel videos but that kind of
makes sense
is what I should put some heavy metal on
the back of that it's also the you know
I use things that are public domain so I
think that is is part of the picture
Karl asks can I recommend some good
works on the idea of reconciliation
especially regarding group to group
nation to nation even idea to idea not
just individual to individual so it
depends on what we're talking about as
reconciliation right if you're
reconciling ideas to ideas I guess you
could say it's more a matter of whether
you can synthesize them together and put
them into some sort of coherent whole if
you're talking about reconciling groups
to groups of Nations to nations it's
usually after some horrible thing
in place and there's a long history of
you know both sides being at odds with
each other and probably selling out a
whole bunch of other people who've been
even more victimized in the process can
I recommend some good works on those
ideas you know I don't read based stuff
but I'm sure there's a lot of things out
there on that but I can't recommend them
because I haven't even really read I can
tell you that you know people like her
or Gabriel Marcel they devoted quite a
bit of thought to that I think hunter
rent does as well and one of the things
that I will say about this notion of
reconciliation it's not something that
you can force upon people because when
you do that you commit
with each other and and genuinely you
know forgive or be let things go there
has to be a process I mean it's a good
it's a good there's a good reason why it
was Truth and Reconciliation committees
and for example South Africa right
because you're not going to get
reconciliation just by everybody saying
oh you know we mistakes were made
let's move on instead there has to be
like a sifting through and and were this
bad and so you know there's probably
like I said a whole literature out there
on this but you could use resources that
are not specifically about Rickett
reconciliation to try to promote that if
they're you know helping you figure out
what really is truth in these
circumstances
alright so jumping back into a sort of
history of philosophy do I think
MacIntyre correctly interprets each
philosopher he discusses in after virtue
I've seen some criticism he got
contoured Kierkegaard and Nietzsche
wrong for example yeah there's an entire
book out there
Murli includes a an essay by mcintyre
sang
I I concede I got wrong I don't think he
got caught wrong I don't think I got
nature wrong I would say that I think he
got the Stoics wrong and that's already
been remarked on by you know a long
couple decades ago after virtue came out
in a pretty famous article like it's
anthologized quite a bit
and I've actually I've given a talk
about how I think he never really got
Ansem right in part because he didn't
engage with it with thumb who turns out
to be quite a history of ideas not just
for the ontological argument which he
didn't even call the ontological
argument but for all sorts of other
things including church state relations
and an understanding of justice and an
analysis of the will McIntyre just sort
of passed over that so yeah Josh asks I
was wondering if you could provide
recommendations on works regarding
existentialism geared towards a layman
or works easier for those just beginning
their journey in philosophy or
psychology I haven't spent a lot of time
with secondary Lit I've mentioned that
many times I'm not I'm not usually good
at recommending that sort of thing much
of the time that I see attempts to you
know sort of popularize and you know
make things simple for for for people it
winds up being so watered down or
oversimplified and incorrect that I'm
not really happy with it so there's
really nothing out there that I
particularly recommend the other thing
too is was
everybody who summarized favorites lists
it's not as if there's a definition of
existentialism Sartre to the contrary
very well you know who you decide count
as the key figures that's going to
influence what you make of the movement
so I mean I know there's an
existentialist Survival Guide recently
written that I'm gonna review hopefully
later this year because I've got it on
my shelf I don't know if it's any good
or not
you know there's existentialism and
romantic love by sky Cleary which it's
okay it's not bad I don't agree with
that on everything but I'll review that
one as well I mean there there really is
no substitute for actually reading
existentialist philosophy and literature
sooner or later you got actually reads
arts or read you know Kierkegaard or
read Nietzsche or read Rilke there's
there's no substitute for it and so you
know I suppose you can get yourself
those you know Nietzsche made easy or
you know those sorts of books but you're
always sort of taking it on faith that
you're getting a decent portrayal of
what's going on in those but I say the
same thing about my videos too I mean if
you think that the videos suffice for
our knowing Plato no you need to read
Plato and then you know the videos are
there is a means to help you out with
that but sooner or later you got to be
going to the texts lateral mirror Lecco
mirror do you take notes while
texts what are your tip being so that
knowledge last longer it can be easily
reflect refract tips you know I've been
reading philosophical texts now for boy
I mean since I was a teen early 20s so
it's something that has become a habit
for me and I'm not not at the beginner
level and I never I never read texts the
way most people did I don't take a lot
of notes I just try to remember what's
going on and I try to you know read the
book and figure out sort of the general
structure of it and if certain things
impress me I mean I do have notes but I
often don't go back to them you know
most of my notes are like from things I
jotted down not well reading but well at
a conference or you know and some spare
moments but you know I've got stacks of
notebooks that I have never gone back to
I don't know what good they do you know
different people have different ways of
reading and what would work for me
probably doesn't work for most people
that's just the way it is so I'm not a
really good guide when it when it comes
to those sorts of things so Adam has one
that looks like it's spread out over a
couple as Plato's Republic analogy to
the human soul or self and then he's got
a question about Hegel to what extent
could the developments of consciousness
be said to be necessary oh these look
like two separate questions and I'm not
sure the first one is actually asking so
let me take the second one
to what extent could the developments of
consciousness be said to be necessary so
Hegel uses that word necessary note
vendee kite right no trendy but clearly
what Hegel means by necessary isn't the
same thing as what's a logicians you
know formal logicians
because Hegel of course has his own
dialectical logic it's not the same
thing as they mean by
so if something is necessary for Hegel
it means that there's some sort of you
know process that we we can reconstruct
and we can see how this led to this led
to this led to this and sometimes things
are driven by a kind of necessity but
you could call it in some respects
necessity light right because he's
trying to make sense of things that are
seem to be contingent history and say
that there's a kind of necessity behind
it if there is a you know a necessity
capital and it's that consciousness has
to develop itself but it doesn't mean
that it's necessary that it happens in
ancient Greece or in you know modern-day
Germany you have to have all the
conditions right for that necessity to
be able to to work itself out and
there's all these different dialectics
can happen at multiple times in multiple
places and people can get stuck in them
and not make any further progress so
it's it's hard to correlate that with
the notion of necessity that many other
people use Nikolaos asks is there a
dialectical response to the losers
philosophy of difference the other
dialectical response quite often is to
say boy to lose he really hates Hegel or
hates hates dialectical philosophy and
you know will return the favor
I'm sure there's there's probably stuff
out there that you can find by people
sort of billing themselves as Orthodox
you know hay galleons or Marxists it's
not stuff that I spend you know any any
time with but I mean there's no reason
why you necessarily have to accept to
lose right or or you could accept part
of two losses ideas and not accept the
rest of them all right you're Mel what
are your thoughts on Nietzsche and why
is he important well so for let's talk
in general with any philosopher it could
be that their ideas are important
because they articulate some some new
concept or they reinterpret somebody's
older concept in a way that a four
something very interesting that we can
sink our teeth into so you know
Nietzsche's work would be valuable if
you know the main idea was that a result
amount in diagnosing that although he's
you know of course not the very first
person you could say that people like
POSCO land and what is his name I'm
blanking on his name not real cold you
know is is diagnosing things like that
as well but Nietzsche articulates it in
a very interesting way or the notion of
the will to power as driving things or
his attack on the possibility of the
unity of the verb choose very
interesting ideas that he's bringing to
the table you can also say that a
philosopher is important because they
have influenced so many other people and
Nietzsche certainly is a philosopher who
has influenced many many people as a
matter of fact that's part of what makes
it hard to pin him down there's so many
different interpretations of nature out
there you know somebody brought up to
lose you lose the great book on
Nietzsche right but what you're gonna
get out of doing
not the same thing as you're gonna get
out of Kaufman or out of Rosen or out of
and we can go on and on and on right so
you know why is Nietzsche important well
because he does contribute ideas and you
know I'll mention another side note if
you want to make contributions the
worlds of ideas it probably helps to
have read pretty extensively in the
world of ideas so you're not you know
pertain to be and you came out when
you're for the most part has done that
right and each has influenced many other
people yeah even if you talking about
like by reaction where they're like well
this nature guy terrible all right
that's that's another reason why we'd
want to read them made of clay are there
any philosophical works that go deep
into despair or hopelessness and if
you're asking that provided analysis of
despair or hopelessness there's quite a
few you know going all the way back into
ancient philosophy there's there's some
schools of philosophy that are looking
at that and saying don't fall into that
right and here's here's what's wrong
with that
if you're asking if there's some that
like take that as their starting point
or even glorify it that's a different
thing and I think you have to look
mostly at more modern philosophy and
literature you know plenty of literature
does that in order to do that some you
know some readings of existentialism are
rather focused on that you know you
think about Beckett and Waiting for
Godot I know it's you know we're
supposed to say it's also such a
wonderful play I don't enjoy it nothing
happens in the play now there's no
movement then again you could actually
say that some of Eugene O'Neill's plays
foul and I kind of despair as well right
about the human condition
and yeah so I mean you can find plenty
of stuff I mean we started talking about
Camus at the beginning and you know they
give the stranger in the mythos if
assists the stuff from his early part of
his career he's beginning with with a
hopeless situation right all right
marco asks what do i think of the work
of Alain Badiou not somebody that I've
looked at for quite some time
yeah I mean I'm not really any judgment
when it comes to him I would have to
invest a lot of time that I don't have
I'm uh
yes
lonna cough did Dostoevsky think his
actions were justified so that's a very
interesting question I think that Bakke
correct in him
problems of dostoevsky's poetics in
saying that you cannot identify
Dostoevsky and his point of view with
any of the characters and their points
of view that he's concerned like like
somebody like Shakespeare with placing
very robust characters with points of
view and and life commitments into
conflict with each other and
experimenting with them and trying to
work out something that has you know
incredibly important ethical import you
could call what import conflicts
implications sometimes it's even very
articulate but that you can't strictly
identify him with any of those which
which is interesting because that would
mean that you can't do it with other
books like blue car so yeah
our Janice what do you think of human
nature in short well that's one of the
problems I think that you can't talk
about it in short I think that the
theory is it's a humans are just this
are usually useful starting points
because they they didn't you know
they're not complete [ __ ] they
didn't come out of nowhere
and they often identified dimensions of
human being but that human nature is
something quite complex both in its
totality and in its social dimensions
and in each individual human being I
think that human nature is something
that you know I mean we are the creature
that actually speculates about its own
nature and I think that a lot of it is
incredibly complex it requires certain
conditions in which it can develop as
much as as possible perhaps we don't
even have an adequate understanding of
the full potentiality of human nature
yet at this point in our development and
yet at the same time we can we if we're
imaginative and we're not you know sort
of egoistic pricks we can identify to
some degree with people in the past who
were afforded less resources for
understanding human nature than some of
the things we have available in the
present because we do share a common
human nature but much of it like I said
remains in potentiality and a good bit
of it winds up being turned aside
corrupted not not you know attaining its
potential and even being directed into
other paths and then you know you that's
just think about us as particular
individuals well every individual exists
within a matrix of relationships you you
know the depth psychologists are correct
about that you know we may not actually
have Oedipus complexes or anything along
those lines
all right and these these formation of
[Music]
you could say so I think that you know
that that's the this is probably a non
answer to you
as it's going to get I think Gabrielle
has an interesting question here which s
where's your favorite stylist so who
writes with the style that I enjoy the
most you know I don't I don't usually
think much about style these days I used
to much more in the past I could go by
process of elimination their philosophy
are quite brilliant but our you know as
far as writers go they're not
particularly good to read and you know
Hegel on Thomas Aquinas and you know
Aristotle you know fit into those sorts
of classifications all of which you
notice our dialectical philosophers who
try to take a lot of other people's
thoughts and bring them together I don't
like the you know let me show off how
clever I am sort of style that that
unfortunately became the mo for
continental philosophy especially for
hacks you know the people who are not
you know the brilliant contributors but
like sort of the just popularizers and
and you know people who make a career
out of writing just on Deleuze orderi
die or Foucault or something like that
they often pick up that kind of style
and it's not particularly good then
again a lot of the style and analytic
philosophy is really you know boring and
pretentious as well me actually like I
mean I like decart I like David Hume I
think I think he's a great stylist I
like you know closer to our time I like
Kierkegaard I like Nietzsche yeah who
else really sticks out to me I mean I
enjoy Cicero but I don't really I can't
say I really love his style I like I
like handsome you know I originally
started enjoying his work not just for
the scope of the ideas I was reading it
Latin but
before how he arranges things and I
would not you know particularly like the
prosto Geum but but also some of the
treaty sees and his prayers and
meditations are quite cool in that
respect all right
bara is their Arabian philosophy or Arab
philosophers yeah there's plenty of Arab
philosophers there's a whole you know
although you know Islamic philosophy has
not sold the Arab right there's people
from all over the place because the
Islamic world is far you know you know
the Quran is in Arabic but Arabs were
Nora tea in the Islamic world and even
in places that were Arabic as the
language not everybody's man really yeah
the Arabic and there's plenty of Arab
philosophers even down to the present
right so you know that that's something
I think is pretty easy to research
memento mori
could I recommend a book that examines
the philosophical background evolution
and effects of the French Revolution
could I recommend a book no because
[Music]
there's no one book that I would look at
but there's plenty of literature out
there on the French Revolution or that's
that's actually sort of part of the
revolution I mean somebody who I teach
you know from semester to semester Marc
Mary Wollstonecraft her you know
vindication of the rights of women is a
document that's directed at the I think
the Minister of Education the French
Revolution and saying that they got some
you know they've got some things wrong
there's there's a vast literature out
there on the Revolution but there's
nothing that for me sticks out as like
the one book that I would I would
recommend canal people always ask what
do you think of Nick land haven't read
of them so and I keep on saying somebody
wants me to say something about Nick
land send me his book you know it's easy
enough to find my my address
and or send me an email and send it Adam
could you explain how Hegel's logic is
supposed to be used if it's used well so
there's two different logics right
there's the Encyclopaedia logic which is
later and then there's the science of
logic and they're both difficult but the
science of logic is more as way way way
more difficult and I I don't really know
how how precisely one would productively
use the totality of the science of logic
I find certain parts of it quite
interesting and insightful but it's you
know it's supposed to provide you with
sort of like that and the phenomenology
are supposed to be like companion pieces
and provide you with the underpinning of
Hegel's entire system I know very very
people that any of those works all the
way through with any level
you
I'd check
over to cover read least a deck so I'm
really a good person to comment than
that but there are parts of it that are
they're quite interesting Rainie Rainie
chief thoughts on hobbes political
philosophy is it grounded in
psychological egoism yeah and it's also
trying to advance beyond that in a
certain kind of contract Arianism that's
based on having a a you know a very
strong sovereign who controls not only
the political environment but even the
educational environment
I see Hobbes is an interesting writer
because he explores what happens when we
screw up when when we allow our passions
to drive us and pretend like we're
rational when we're really not and he
describes how cultures break down and I
think that there is a great danger of
Hobbesian situations being developed so
he articulates a kind of logic of human
conflict in action that isn't isn't
necessary but can can easily occur if
we're not careful so I view him as
somebody worth reading he's kind of
interesting to to check out Adam asked
who I like ggx jokes I don't really read
much Dziedzic these days and I mean some
of his jokes are funny
I don't pay
I he's recently about this topic or that
topic of this topic and I'm looking at
what he has to say about culture and
politics and and all that I mean making
jokes is okay
and he can get away with doing a lot of
that but particularly interested in that
because I don't have a hell of a lot of
time for that
yeah do I think that people who believe
in a personal God err and cannot escape
their own ignorance without shattering
their own egos I'd say maybe some of
them are but I I think that most aren't
and I mean if that's what you think
about people who believe in a personal
God then either you you know drew upon a
very very uncharacteristic and small
sample or you're operating with some
pretty sweeping ideological assumptions
about the leaf and a personal God so
there are you know there are
philosophers out there who who espoused
that point of view but usually it's
interesting the people who like
complaining about the Crusades and the
Inquisition and all that and treat that
as if that's what you know religion is
really about and our secularists for
that extent they're usually Crusaders
inquisitors themselves so that's the
same sort of thing which which has very
little to do with religion and much more
to do with satisfying emotional needs
and and you know psychological damage
and the need for you know absolute
certainty and all that sort of stuff
it's a good place to go back to the Nita
thing right Nietzsche in the genealogy
would condemn those people just as much
as you would any theologian or
metaphysical philosopher all right it's
on us do you think it's important before
tackling
worked predecessors for example reading
the rationalist and empiricist before
car no um but I think
read a philosopher at multiple times and
maybe the first
stuff and then you go back and read the
earlier stuff and you know sometimes
when you do that you're like you know
can't said that this Descartes guy was
doing this but man he's it doesn't seem
like the count was actually right about
this yeah often you have that experience
no you don't have to have like a you
know super background and every single
thing before you go on to the next thing
in philosophy but it's an iterative
process expect to go back and forth I
think a lot of people get very
preoccupied with what what order do I
have to do things in as if philosophy
was some sort of technical field where
first you have to learn this code and
then you then you can move on to this
next platform and you can't understand
one without the other that's just not
the case at all you know all right
Kunal have you read any 20th century
Italian philosophy like Croce gentille
I've read some Croce a long time ago I
also read blanking on his name starts
with a c' he was a big he is interested
in Vico student of Heidegger connected
with Maurice blown-down as well I can't
remember his name offhand but if that
tells you how long it's been since I
read him him
mystical tradition in in philosophy
I enjoyed when I would I read Croce it's
been I only read a few things have been
so long that I can't really remember
what I made of him so I mean if you
count autumn man is 20th century Italian
philosophy could say I read him you know
but he's not really 20th century he's
straight into the 21st century and I
like our men all right Jonah
I don't have one anymore than I have a
favorite band I just have a lot of
people who I enjoy and and you know
every once in a while I come up with the
top ten list they change so made of clay
what did Kierkegaard mean that when you
try to prove God's existence it actually
ends up doing the opposite in the
individual well so Kierkegaard considers
this at a couple points and there's
different ways to try to prove God's
existence all right
one is too
effort you know to try to keep up
probabilities and you still see people
doing this kind of thing today as if
somehow we could accumulate enough that
we could induce the notion that God
exists and Kierkegaard thought that
you're never gonna really reach the end
of that you could always still have
doubts so and even if you did produce it
what kind of guy do you get this is a
common complaint not just Kierkegaard
but other people point this out Pascal
you know laying chest off you know if
you if you think about like some of the
traditional metaphysical proofs of God's
existence so what kind of guy do they
give you think about Aquinas as Fiveways
okay so there's a there's a first mover
and that we call God well yeah I guess
that would be an aspect of God but that
sure as hell isn't what religious people
mean when they think about God the prime
mover the necessary being you know and
so you know already in Pascal's time he
says there's a big difference between
the god of the the philosophers on the
God of Abraham Isaac and Jacob and so
when we when we engage in these sort of
deductive and we
we center our our our whole lives
comportment on that then Kierkegaard
would say we're sort of mistaking what
the whole things about essential because
you know the critic of hegel hegel
thinks that art
yes the point is not to prove that guy
stead is to help us better understand
what it is that we mean by God so you
know this actually jives quite well with
with so you know what somebody like and
so and some didn't come up with an
ontological arguments come up with an
ontological arguments you just read
Proust low Jian two through four you
might you know as you would if you were
doing a philosophy of religion class
you'll see it labeled the ontological
argument and some didn't call it that
can't call it that and so I'm actually
we talked about having one argument
running through the entirety of the pro
slogan which is designed not just to
prove that God exists or has being davis
esse but that god is the good that all
other goods need in order to be good and
everything else that we believe about
God and if you look through you know
past chapter four to chapter five and
all the way to the the komyatti onus at
the end the last three chapters which
are not part of the argument there's
sort of a continuing of the argument and
some is actually proving or arguing for
or providing an account of a lot more
now if you read back towards the start
why does he write all this stuff down
does he write it down to convince the
unbeliever of of the existence of God no
he he struggles trying to come up with
this wound amarga mentum and when he
sees it he is filled with such you know
positive emotion that he thinks that
other people might have a similar
response so in in some respects it's an
aesthetic response
or argument right there's there's a
affective aspect to this and I think
that's something very important in
philosophy that often gets left out and
Kierkegaard you know this is not coming
back to him he calls faith the highest
passion and there's a good reason why he
views it that way
to
so then I would say your cougar
that's same tradition that Ansem does of
faith seeking understanding not you know
seeking knock-down drag-out arguments
but trying to figure out well okay I
believe in something and I'm not even
quite sure what it is that I believe it
what the hell am I talking about here
what what what is this relationship with
God and I'll sing one other thing too
because it looks like we're getting a
lot of questions about religion here
I like religious authors for whom
finding religion or being religious
doesn't solve all their problems but it
actually makes things more complicated
because reality is complicated if
there's a God and God is part of the
picture God should not provide you with
the answers for everything and
everything falls into place God should
among and if you look at you know a lot
of kalitta Chur think about the Sermon
on the Mount that's you know people like
to talk about that and so long as you do
at arm's length
you know this Jesus guy is really cool
and he's you know so nice and all that
read it read Matthew 5 through 7 then
think about wow if this is true how do I
fit into that do I actually measure up
to any of this would I be any of the
people being being talked about as
blessed are you know these or do I do
the things that I'm not supposed to do
and do I do I live up to any of this
it's tough tough tough stuff right and
and then I can respect and care go
Nik Ken Maurice merleau-ponty thought be
incorporated into his perspective that
involves the transcendental such as
religion or is his philosophy
antithetical to transcending outside
perception well it's not as if
everything is just within perception and
even if it was even Berkeley you know
for whom SAS / Kippy right has God as
and has spirits within it I'd say
Marilyn poems he is work can easily be
adapted but you would have to you know
depart from him on some things and
that's what we do with with adaptation
or incorporation I think you could even
do that with Camus who's much more
trench into the metal Ponte is kind of
agnostic Camus is definitely an atheist
right Bruno down mullah and what are
some philosophers which are more carried
by emotions as well that's a really
interesting so you could be asking were
the philosophers who really gave
attention to the emotions the proper
attention they deserve
and acknowledge their place and their I
would include people from Plato and
Aristotle all the way to you know
important phenomenology just like his
mock Schaller or you know Edith Stein
and you know all of them
but then you could be asking the
question well Nietzsche of course on the
way to it acknowledges how emotions fit
in you could be asking a different
question which i think is actually much
more interesting who despite all their
talk about reason and logic and science
and you know deduction and all this sort
of stuff who's really driven by emotion
and I think that the answer is a lot
more people than then realize that they
are and I'm just basing this sort of on
my own experience with many people who
love to talk endlessly about that sort
of stuff but behave in very emotional
ways I mean if you're shouting at me
about how you know science has proven
this or that you're shouting at me why
are you so angry
you know why is the anger driving
something rather than whatever that
you're you know your logic or science or
reason to pick whatever else you want to
talk about why isn't that actually
having to take a measured approach to
things keeping some perspective right
robos ask me about somebody who I don't
know Nicolas Gomez Davila so I don't
have any thoughts on that person um
jeito more it would be awesome to see
John David Ebert on Hegel his YouTube
channel is amazing off to take your word
for that I barely have time to get my
work done let alone watch or listen to
other people although I do you know go
on other people's channels and podcasts
from time to time by invitation just
actually did two podcast episodes this
week with other other people so if you
know if you want to put a bug in his ear
go ahead and we'll see what happens
philosopher add when I say Aristotle's
theory of ethics is primarily an
inductive argument I wouldn't say
Aristotle's theory of our ethics is an
argument so that's kind of a non-starter
right there
and I would add I've said this you know
like in job interviews or it might have
cost me my job
I think Aristotle is actually doing
phenomenology of moral life before we
called it phenomenology
something that by the way gotta myrrh
and Heidegger and the rent would all
agree with as well and record but
there's an an argument there to his
theory of ethics there's an entire
contexture of a whole bunch of arguments
and explanations and accounts there's
not one single thing I think maybe this
is coming from that notion that you know
Plato was a rationalist and Aristotle
was an empiricist which is really bunk
Aristotle was more of an empiricist
Plato was also a you know directed
towards the empirical leave it wasn't
all just in his head and Aristotle's got
plenty of rationalist elements to his
work as do you empiricists like Locke
it's or even here than in some respects
you can't get away from from believing
in something without having you know
inductively based evidence for it so you
know you you know if you want to know
what Aristotle's theory of ethics is got
to go to the nikah McCain ethics the you
Demian ethics the politics because it's
also in there the topics particularly
book 3 on the sole because there's
discussion of human motivation in there
for actions poetics and the rhetoric so
that's Aristotle's ethics as far as
we're able to put them together even
some other things like the probe LaMotta
where you want to look in that so yeah I
mean you could say that some arguments
are inductive arguments but they're
they're not necessarily induction in the
way that's a male uses that so
all right
never literally thousands of books out
there I'm Nietzsche so that has thing to
do with with me already with with you
know me not not reading a lot of other
stuff I just skipped up a little bit
looks like there's a lot of questions
here
Arvid well we ever reach the point where
all relevant philosophical knowledge
will simply be too much for anyone to
learn or understand in a single lifetime
I think we've already reached that and
that poses some interesting problems for
us doesn't it and I think we've I think
we've probably reached that before I was
even born I was born in 1970 so I think
that there's so much stuff out there
that you can't possibly assimilate all
of it so we have to kind of go on a sort
of by faith you know we've got some
faith that you know these thinkers are
worth spending time with and then you
know kids corroborated by actually going
into their work Adam has a good question
here do I agree with Francis Fukuyama
that we've reached the end of history
it's clear that Hegel was wrong but
still I don't think Fukuyama even
himself believes that anymore as far as
I know I think that dad had already gone
out of the picture by our posthuman
future when she wrote early
two-thousands I think no I don't think
we've reached the end of history
I think we're this goes back to that
question about human nature too I don't
think that we fully understand
and all of its potential it's complex's
so there
and because of configurations I mean I
kind of think like Mary Wollstonecraft
and Rainer Maria Rilke does that dealing
with gender relations and thinking
through them and making some sort of
progress towards really quality and not
just sort of a formal legal equality nor
a grudging
if
to eople without demanding that they you
know check our boxes I think that is
good to be eight I don't know we're
heading
future which actually strikes me as kind
of boring be much more hetero but I
don't think we're anywhere close to the
end of history and it could be that we
go into cul de sacs you know perhaps we
are headed back towards a time where
various forms of you know
authoritarianism arise that look similar
to the fascism and and military
dictatorships and National Socialism and
you know sort of counterpose to
essentially you know really quite
rightist communist regimes maybe that's
where we're headed and well you know
theocratic regimes maybe liberal
democracy becomes beleaguered and
disappears again or maybe a liberal
democracy is kind of [ __ ] and that's
part of why it succumbs because you know
ordinary people are like well the
corporation's do run everything and they
control the government and nobody wants
to get anything done
maybe that's maybe that's where we do a
detour again you know it's worth
reflecting on this there's this notion
that for example think about fascism
that fascism was anti modern and some of
the great you know researchers out there
in the 2000s we're pointing out fair a
schism was not anti modern at all it
proposed a different vision of modernity
and I think we could say something
similar about what's going on in the
Chinese communist corporated state
controls an awful lot right we may see
something similar happen
deep under the BJP we may see something
in similar arise within the the Islamic
world you know liberal democracy is is
not the only possible game in town and
it's got to get its act together if it
wants to be the driving force for for
history the way it was in the second
half of the 20th century and going in to
the early
miss for a little while and it could
also be that we we end the history you
know if if we really are playing an
important role in global warming in
addition to you know normal cycles and
stuff like that which seems like most of
the evidences we are and we don't have
the political will to fix that maybe we
script this planet so it revocable or we
do so through pollution you know killing
the oceans or you know just burying
ourselves with trash perhaps we do that
and there is no more history so those
are those are key issues takes us far
from Fukuyama wholesome which English
dictionary do you I use or recommend
when reading or teaching philosophy I
don't recommend dictionaries as a matter
of fact dictionaries quite often in
philosophy are misleading because the
way philosophical terms are used quite
often is not their dictionary definition
I hate papers that begin with Webster's
defines blah blah blah as blah battle
blocks I'm like well this is definitely
somebody who doesn't doesn't have
anything to say
this starting point I I want you know if
I'm asking somebody to write about
Aristotle or Plato they better be
starting Aristotle or Plato not Miriam
Webster
so yeah Adam were
[Music]
oh so you know right now when it comes
to in scene I am more disenchanted with
the right and view them is more of a
threat than I do the left but there have
been parts at times in my life where it
was the opposite so I don't need leaf it
into to that alright um there's a lot of
back and forth here Lieber prima is
there a necessity to life well I guess
not I mean you can always end it right
right now custody now I don't know what
else we were talking about it here
Gabrielle what Hegel's necessity be
similar to Lyman says certainty as
espoused in Lyman says discourse on
metaphysics that's a good question and I
would say it's similar but it's not the
same right because in I don't see in
Lyman says discourse on metaphysics a
dynamic development theory the way there
is in history rather it's you know God
selected this you know best of all
worlds and everything we do is in some
degree determined you know he actually
gotten some really interesting debates
with with Clark about freedom and
necessity and but I don't know
whether a fly well I'm reading about
skepticism and having a hard time
distinction
is the me what exorcism is an equivocal
term so it's not as if it always names
the same thing
instead the skepticism of the Academy
which already was divided be people like
arcus allows and then you know people
like cardio days who accepted a theory
of probability that influences Cicero
so skepticism doesn't name just one
thing fallibilism is a term that's
coined much later on and to a large
degree it overlaps with with you know
sort of you know a healthy skepticism
right just means that you say that you
could be wrong about stuff and certain
skeptics could say that you couldn't oh
that some skeptics are so extremely so
you can't have any knowledge at all even
about whether you can have knowledge so
it depends on what kind of skepticism
you're talking about rave acts beastly
do I think there's deep similarities
between antics structural realism into
Louisiana ontology I wouldn't know
exciton take structural realism
if we only want what we get will we
always get wheat we want no no because
you may not get wheat you may get barley
or you may get nothing all right but
that's that's an easy one to solve by
our again is the thesis antithesis
synthesis concept attributable to Hegel
I always thought it was common sense
amazing if it originated from him
well it originates from him to some
degree but it's really a bastardization
of what Hegel was doing by later
Hegelians and a lot of the times that
you see the word antithesis and Hegel
it's not in a thesis antithesis
synthesis triad he does it more in some
works than he does in others it's
useless for interpreting the
phenomenology for example so and you
know if that's common sense to you it's
you mean very something very different
by common sense and what most people
mean by common sense because it's not
common sense to most people so you may
feel that you probably you feel an
affinity for it or you think the world
works that way Hegel doesn't it works
that way because the world is actually
more complicated than this this three
Susan
this has become the new thesis for
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
so Adam why do you prefer Western
philosophy over oriental well I wouldn't
call it oriental to begin with because
that's kind of a racist term and there
is no such thing as Eastern philosophy
in in the sense that there's like
Western and then Eastern the Indian
tradition is just as rich and is
important as the Western tradition and
it's as different from the Chinese
tradition although they have some
similarities because of you know
Buddhism crossing the Himalayas as it is
from the Chinese tradition right and
then we have you know where does the
Islamic world fit in there too is it
part of the West is it non Western and
why do I prefer Western philosophy over
Eastern or non Western philosophies
I don't it's just where my area of
competency is it's what I
you know I like to stick with things
where I can actually read the original
texts if you know the original language
is if possible I don't read poly and
overt Sanskrit I don't read Mandarin
although I took a stab at it a while ago
and that wouldn't be enough to teach me
classic Chinese anyway I don't read
Japanese you know I don't read Arabic I
don't read Farsi I don't read you know
the things that I would need to make to
really make a foray into it I probably
won't have the time in in the years that
are left to me to actually do
things
proponents of Massa fee I just you know
when I teach us I don't know the same
capacity to go back to the texts the way
I do with Plato right and so I don't
present myself as the with the level of
expertise that that I do when it comes
to Western philosophy so and I live in
the West you know why wouldn't I want to
read Descartes or humor
Hobbes or these people all right an
animus what are my thoughts on Bitcoin
well I'm not invested in Bitcoin and at
this point I don't take so you know I'll
wait and see when I cash my groceries
with it then I'll probably still care
about it but until then it's a pretty
speculative thing and I you know I I
have friends were super into it and I
listen to what they have something I
take the time to research or form
thoughts of myself tt most of your
videos focus on philosophy before the
20th century have you thought about
including more philosophers in
philosophy from the late 20th century
yeah I mean I've got some stuff American
tire I've got some stuff on ethics of
care a lot of the stuff that I've shot
is from my classes and we rarely get to
23 thing
why did the sequence on heidegger's
Plato's allegory of the cave that was a
commission set of core concept videos I
don't have unlimited time and you know I
read and work on a lot of mid to late
20th century philosophers but you know
there's there's important gaps that I
need to fill in either for my own
students or for I think you know YouTube
in general because other people aren't
doing it and when I get done with that
then maybe a lot of time for for doing
stuff on 20th century thinkers now have
I thought about making videos on Carl
Jung know quite frankly and there's many
many other people that I would want to
shoot videos on before I get to them and
there seems like there's so many other
people interested in Carl you know some
contributors on you there aren't that
many people interested in or competent
to talk about many of the other thinkers
who I is on and that's sort of like
triage you got to do that stuff first
[Music]
all right
or
in what way did the patent relation does
one subordinate the other or they wished
yeah I think they are intermeshed
Aristotle defines the prior ASIS which
is for him this capacity for choosing
that that is at the core of our
character it's not quite the same thing
as Epictetus is pro races which is
getting close to the conception of the
will but he thinks that that is is the
interface between our not just the
passions but the desirous effective part
of ourselves the owner axis right and
the Aristotle divides a rack system to
the laces we have translated as rational
desire will the desires or appetites
themselves and then through most this
middle part you know all of those things
are part of our exes and then we have
the intellectual part of ourselves your
reasoning part of ourselves noose or da
Noya and he says that pry raíces is a
nexus D&O antique a meaning desire
informed by reason the name of my blog
by the way our exes do you know what
decay or noose or rectum coasts right
mind infused by desire or F activity
those those combined that's the juncture
point in what we later on identify as
the will a lot of people though there's
no such thing as the will well they
probably mean something different than
what you know Epictetus or Augustine or
Cicero or anything other people are
engaging in discussion of and yeah
there's there's a possibility of reason
unfortunately fitting into Humes slave
status reason can only be the slave of
the passions right and some people
that's the case this is not the case for
all of us but it is the case for some
people because they haven't developed
or habit right and they never step out
of that box and whatever work we do is
always iterative right so that's what I
have to say about that payroll bot seon
are there any philosophers we can read
that will help us understand gun rights
or the right to defend yourself well
that's an interesting question because
the whole debate about gun rights needs
to be informed by the fact that you know
some sort of empirical stuff it's super
easy to get guns it's super easy to kill
people with contemporary guns right and
and you know I mean the ring of guy Gees
is to create a thought experiment
because you think about
that here in amid gas and the near to
stop them in most cases
gets shot by the cops or oftentimes
can't get his or her gun out in time
yeah I mean there's there's lots of
philosophy you'd want to start reading
in a philosophy of conflict and look at
what classical philosophers have to say
about it and think about whether that
sort of power should be in the hands of
a lot of people and we should also start
thinking about whether we in America I
want to have some sort of federal policy
other than hands off been up to every
we will solve
Hey
sanctuary cities right so Republicans
complain because immigrant being in
these sanctuary cities and there's no
you know control over that and it
affects people outside of the sanctuary
cities well if you're in Chicago you
have the opposite problem because
there's a whole sanctuary state of
Indiana where there's totally lacks gun
control and most of the guns in Chicago
are coming in from Indiana or other
places where they were they're purchased
easily and often illegally so we
probably need some sort of federal
policy and it would take some sort of
rethinking to do that Paul moussa I'm an
academic weighing my job options which
quite frankly you don't have a lot of
them right from that Academy what is the
status of teaching philosophy at
communities so that's a great
because Community College jobs are
actually quite sought-after
it's usually you know expect you to
teach a lot write a standard load at a
community college for teaching is a 5/5
so for a lot of people that's that's too
much for them but that's because they
you know they're not used to working
it's hard right I always you know I I'm
actually teaching five classes this
semester and five classes last semester
for different institutions
I've taught as many as eight classes a
semester in my previous places and four
years I taught you know five or six
classes per semester I have zero
sympathy whatsoever for anybody who's
teaching a three-three and so
you know but and you know you're giving
me
mmm and some of them are gonna be quite
academically challenged many of them are
not going to be particularly interested
in in whatever it is that your teacher
a good teacher
pay up community in states and counties
where there is a real sense of the
importance of education and a strong
union movement or used to be a strong
union movement pay is often pretty good
at community colleges in part because
usually they're aligned with the traits
in states where that's not the case pay
can be quite low so the other good thing
though is 10
[Music]
I'm all [ __ ] up
school or a county school but it could
be quite good and I would apply for it
all right
musical elements what did I think about
neuroscience psychology is a basic
favored behavior and philosophy I think
that a lot of what is called
neurosciences and science at all its
pseudoscience and we have to do a lot of
work to parse out the stuff that's
really good science from the stuff
that's kind of rocky very small sample
sizes fudge data and you know we also
should ignore most of what science
journalists tell us about what
neuroscientists and said because they're
almost always wrong
I think that the people who are placing
their all their eggs
it know what years ago that said it
doesn't mean we should throw all of it
you know like we do with everything else
sort of look at it carefully sift
through what it has to teach us and be
very you know careful and skeptical
about its claims and then it can be
connected up with with philosophy but
neuroscience doesn't replace philosophy
psychology is not a single term right it
names a whole bunch of different things
many of which are disconnected from each
other so you know that's kind of a good
thing to point out all right
liebherr premise one of my thoughts on
post-modernism those are this many time
so I'm gonna make this super quick I
think most I think there is no one
single thing you can point out as
post-modernism I think most people that
are talking about post-modernism have no
clue about what they're talking about
and many of them actually end up fitting
the bill of what theorists of
post-modernism what identify as
postmodern you know so I think if you
want to talk productively about
post-modernism you better run Liotta
can I get Jameson's both Muslim and read
through that as well you for the talk
productively about this incredibly
complex thing ax ax thoughts on the
differences between Hagel and
Heidegger's account to the synthetic a
priori and cut I couldn't say that I
have thoughts on that it's not something
I've been thinking about for a while
so I don't have anything productive to
say about that
all Arcola what are your thoughts on
Julius of volos metaphysics of war
haven't read it so I can't say anything
about that Ken Roberts any thoughts on
Thomas Merton reading him got me
introduced to philosophy via a Tianjin
song spirit of medieval philosophy
though he's not considered a philosopher
Merton sometimes considered a
philosopher he's usually considered a
spiritual writer right especially
because of seven story mountain
he's somebody worth reading I you know I
think he's kind of also a product of his
times there there wasn't that much
comparative work being done at the time
and I'm gonna write him for for quite
some time I know quite a few people who
really enjoy him so you know and anybody
in the Benedictine tradition is usually
worth reading so alright bara what do
you think of Kant's philosophy of
aesthetics well I'm talking about the
third critique the critique of judgment
it's quite interesting it's kind of a
mishmash right it doesn't have I would
say the the sort of straightforward
continuity that the first and second
critiques do but it's some of his most
interesting stuff we actually did a
reading group on the critique of
judgment when I was a graduate student
and we had to stop because because so
many of the people were having trouble
following it but if you know I teach
some of it occasionally like I will be
teaching a bit of it this this time
around
hopefully in this ethics of ethics for
artists and designers and and maybe even
a little bit in an intro class but it's
just a smallest amount of it you know
what's that what is the sublime what is
the beautiful you know that sort of
stuff alright let's see what we got here
[Music]
Klim
that's tough to say I mean
it would be like an event in world
history I mean it could be I mean it
could be in some respects the you know
the trump presidency although that's
maybe getting too much importance to
America
you know India and China are massively
important on the world scene as well but
you know and I would say that the the
trump presidency is largely important
because of what it would had put an end
to or stymied or prevented more than
what it accomplished you know for
example we maybe we could have actually
had some sort of Accord
to try to do something about climate
change before it kills all of us which
it may well do it's certainly not the
sort of thing that we should be taking
risks with you know and saying oh no no
it's not doing anything you know we're
not sure about the science that's that's
sort of you know that was fine like 15
years ago to be that kind of skeptic
nowadays people say that's for some I
just too
you know punk dice when it comes to like
what what the future is gonna look like
I don't know maybe maybe what's going on
in China is really more important than
what's going on in America you know I
don't know that's a very tough one to
say but I don't think there's an event
as much
you
no they ever actually everybody loves it
there's an inventor
you
for most to critique
style of writing are there any good
critiques of his ideas and where could I
read them there's lots of critiques of
his idea
some of them are alone that you know
Karl Popper is a great example who's not
criticizing Hegel style so much but
rather sort of was his ideas lead to
crushing the individual and bagels the
proto-fascist and all that but it's not
it's not really that good of a reading
his Hegel was actually liberal of the
time I mean you know there's there's all
sorts of of criticisms of Hegel but
often times they get sucked into you
know being kind of hegelian themselves
you could think of Marx as a critic of
Hegel all right but Marx is also drawing
significantly upon him so all right
tt what do you think of an arco
primitivism and and those authors and
I'm not even quite sure what an arco
prayer as I imagine it's sort of like a
back to nature living in a tent sort of
thing I think that you know it's
probably divided up into like the true
believers who do it and then you know
the rich kids who try it on as a
lifestyle choice for a while but I could
be wrong about that of course because I
don't really know a lot of anarcho
primitiveness doesn't strike me as
something that could be you know a real
starter for contemporary political
discussion but you know that's I could
be wrong all right Nicola can I fully
understand Nietzsche with being familiar
only with ancient philosophy Thanks
maybe now maybe it helps to know
something about Christianity and about
Kant and about you know medieval and
modern history and that sort of thing so
but you know you can understand plenty
of what he's saying you can't
or could you explain coming
rebellion in one minute
probably not but I'll say that's so Kant
thinks that there's more than one kind
of rebellion to begin with but in
rebelling we reconstitute a sir we
constitute ourselves as human beings we
say this is intolerable and it's not
just intolerable for me in this respect
it's intolerable for me as a human being
and very often this this involves a kind
of solidarity although there's often
selling out of other people too and he
does say that thing in rebelling
you know we exist right so there's a
plurality and a a bringing together
other people through it but there's a
lot of different types of rebellion Kyle
was Beyond Good and Evil originally a
stoic concept nope because the Stoics
talk about good and evil they they think
that some of the things that we think
are good and evil aren't really good and
evil but they definitely believe in good
and evil and those are the most
important things virtue vice right so no
if that's not a stoic concept means
misteni
no Kyle Roble
really enjoyed reading them because
Rabelais is so over-the-top crazy
the stuff that goes on he's a great
master of comedy the great you know as
my uncle John used to say you know a
great raconteur of [ __ ]
you know that that sort of his vision
I went out in Europe in the summer of 95
and I was staying with you know excited
it was I didn't have a lot of money so I
bought a Eurail pass I got a plane
ticket there I worked for a year and
every month I'd save like 200 bucks you
know living in this tiny a little rat
trap apartment eating you know very
cheaply working overtime and save about
200 bucks and I would I would put that
into the European currency Marx francs
and what else did I get
French francs Marx and Swiss francs yeah
and then I I went to Europe and I was
staying with a friend no I was staying
with it with it with the sister of a
friend inns are broken which was right
across the border from Metz
literally the you know bridge on desire
I'd broken and so we crossed over into
Metz and Metz was not a tourist town you
know it was just not set up for the kind
of visiting all the different things but
one of the things that was on there was
the Maison Robley so I was like wow we
got to go see this because I really like
rah bleh
so we're wandering through these streets
and eventually we do find it and we're
like is this the right place
because it's just like you know a house
with you know kind of a fence around it
a stone fence and inside the house
there's a bar and it's got a tower and
and I was like is this the Rob Lai house
no I can't Rob Lee lived
there's the plaque you can read it and
you guys are a bar and restaurant yeah
but it was kind of a rundown sort of
place and then I was like well can we
poke around there like knock yourself
out do whatever you want you know just
you get a bite you're gonna buy
something so he we did and we went up
this this tower and there are some
pigeons living up there and nothing else
and I thought wow I think for somebody
like Rob like kind of silly it's kind of
you know sign of what happens over time
yeah it was quite an experience all
right Brennan asks what are you reading
at the moment in scholarship and for
pleasure though those are antiques
yeah I'm trying to get ready for
yeah
so Cicero's on fate I shot a whole
sequence of videos on that as well
they'll release much later on and we
just did Poe for the worlds of
speculative fiction and I have
Chesterton coming up so that'll be kind
of fun
we're doing his man who was Thursday in
the ball on the cross and what a few
other ones as well in that one but I
don't actually have the time to do any
pleasure reading that's not connected
with talks or classes or things like
that right now and I'm gonna be doing a
lot of reading for my my classes but a
lot of its rereading or his reading
stuff that I've been reading for years
and years and years but you always got
to bone up again before you teach it so
all right let's see Daniel asks have you
read or at least no simple kiyose of
Colicchio's commentary and enchiridion
of apik titus yes i have read it and
it's okay I didn't find it all that
illuminating on the points that I was
looking for illumination for
particularly epictetus notion of Pro
racists that's when I went to simply
kiyose when I was giving that that talk
back at Marquette a couple years ago on
epictetus --is notion of cry race that's
what exactly what it meant and
unfortunately I you know Epictetus is is
there
and his prior asus is the Faculty of
choice and the Faculty of choice and the
rational faculty in the hegemony cone
these are three different ways of
looking at the same thing for epictetus
not so for the other Stoics and the only
other person who uses prior asus in that
sort of sense is aristotle as a matter
of fact
Epictetus who's supposed to not know any
aristotle you know according to some of
the scholars it's very funny because
prior asus and you know what's a Pomona
and Oak at Boulogne that's also an
Aristotle that's also important in the
Aristotelian tradition so clearly
Epictetus drew on Aristotle in the
Aristotelian tradition to some degree
that's a side note but yes implicit said
prior ace this is just you know high
racists Pro high and racist you know
choice before choice and he didn't
really follow it out further so I was
kind of disappointed with that but you
know he's worth checking out me smiston
should I buy walter benjamin's house
caveats of Erica or Graham skis prison
notebooks one two and three I can't
decide I don't know I if I if I was
gonna buy stuff that lows are what I
would you know Chris but I don't really
buy a lot of books anymore because I've
got too many books already and I have
people who send eight books to Ava I
would you say there are useless
philosophical questions that are more
like a game a form of exercise for the
mind but insignificant at the core yeah
I'd say like half of the stuff that's
published these days fits that we're
done in presentations or you go to
conferences near like Jesus why am i
listening to this drivel you know and
the people are so earnest about it is
being very important and you're like man
this is exactly why people get turned
off on philosophy so yeah all right so
I've got two minutes left and I and then
I've got to get to a client meeting
so let me take here's a good question to
end on Danny no Rossler doctor say they
are wondering are you no longer working
in academia as a philosopher I was
wondering under your thoughts about
pursuing such a career well you've heard
me talk about the classes I'm teaching
so clearly I am still working in
academia I'm not working as a professor
I'm I'm a job so and I and I've been one
since 2011 when I left my full-time
position at Fayetteville State
University as a professor but I've been
teaching you know pretty consistently
throughout all of this this time and
right now I'm actually teaching more
than full time I'm teaching five classes
even at most places a four four is a
full load and I have to start saying no
because I'm now in a fortunate position
where I get more requests for teaching
than I can fill in part because I've
developed a reputation as being a really
good teacher somebody who's really
reliable and the students you know
really respond well to so it's what I'm
doing
but you know the academic teaching that
takes time away from shooting videos
creating you know personal enrichment
classes resources from our clients doing
my own writing
on the side so it keeps me a very busy
person I will probably always be
teaching
you
do that and it's good you know there's a
it gives me access to university
libraries but I don't like
like Oh every academic you know
arbitrary so many of the things that we
we end up having to do are you know why
a 15 week semester you know that's not
the best way to teach why why does it
things have to be done this way you know
sort of done this way over here at this
school so I'll probably yeah like you
know I said I'll probably always be
doing some teach a somewhere but I two
moves you know having my audience in my
teachable classes or things like that so
I didn't get to everybody's questions
never do because there's always so many
of them but I did get to as many as they
could we'll do another one of these next
month and for everybody wherever you
happen to be I hope you have a great
evening or night morning afternoon and
good rest of the weekend and I'll see
you somewhere else in the internets